- I’m off to find another disgruntled vet.
I left detailed instructions, but make sure you protect the Lombardi Trophy!
- Yeah, yeah.
- Of course!
- You know me: Get me started early, or I'll throw a lil fit!
LET’S PARTY.
[Groaning]
The only person supporting us is YG again.
- So we had a three-deep fire zone, brought the nickel off the edge and the safety dropped down, ya know?
- Word, Imma use that in Madden.
[Doorbell ringing]
- That must be Whitworth with the brie!
- Cincy here to win the natty.
- HOLY F--KING S--T! THE COOL KIDS! AYO, COME THROUGH!
- Was anyone expecting the Bengals?
- Uh-oh. I heard they bring the house down.
- IT’S GETTING PRETTY LATE. TIME TO TURN IN?
- COOL. WE’RE GONNA KEEP GOING.
- We just won’t let them go off—
[Thumping]
- Yo, my bad. The bookshelf was talking s--t.
- ♪♪♪ IT’S THE J-O-SINGLE-E. BURROW! ♪♪♪
- Oh, sup, LeBron?!
-  YO, BURROW! EM!
I’VE NEVER BEEN TO A PARTY WITH TWO CHILL WHITE DUDES.
♪♪♪
- UH, BEEN A RIDE OR DIE SINCE WEEK 10.
- I’m beginning to feel like I’m a YAC god, YAC god.
- I’m Leonardo DiCaprio, and I do NOT care what sport this is.
- Aight, hear me out: You replace Brodie.
♪♪♪
- I got Zac Stacks, y'all!
- Please be careful. Please—
I DID NOT LEAVE DETROIT FOR THIS.
- REMEMBER: DETROIT NEVER LEAVES YOU.
- Yes, Mr. Mathers.
- Man, I wish Gridiron Heights taught me about saving money.
- We got surprisingly great rates at State Farm.
- This show IS perfect!
- So I don’t even use protection.
- ALL RIGHT, ENOUGH. THREE AND OUT YOU GO.
- Sorry, guy, I kind of just do whatever the f--k I goddamn please.
- That worry on your face? That’s McFEAR, SON!
- [Cheering together:] LET’S GO, GUY FROM BENGALS DEFENSE!
- DO NOT TEST ME. I WILL GO DOWN IN FLAMES.
- THIS IS OUR HOUSE.
Well, we share it, but still.
- Are we all in?
- YES. F--K THEM PICKS!
- Hey, look, my keys still work!
[Alarm sounding]
- Damn, he’s gotten good at the silent count.
- Not much of a Chase.
- Man, you’re just trash...talking.
- [Grunting]
- ♪♪♪ Stop all this football drama in this dancery. ♪♪♪
- Looks like some sort of football fight broke out at a well-produced
hip-hop dancery.
- No matter what happens, hell of a party.
- [Coughing]
- Are you choking?
- I don't do that anymore.
- Is that...Zac?
How the hell you'd get here?
- WHAT?! HUH. JUST A LIL ZAC NAP!
SO WHAT I LET LOOSE AND HAD FUN?
YOU’RE NOT MY DAD ANYMORE!
- Zac, you’re two years older than me.